all right welcome back to the second
thanks for having me it's a pleasure to
be here so my talk will be on a bit
about different topics with compare with
I guess the most of the top in the
workshops so short diversion how big
bleep right so yes as joe said i'm going
to talk about some combat oriole
problems
geez there's a long history of using
linear algebra in the context of combat
area optimization there's a lot of gems
in the past and new for development for
example Rabin and Viviani algorithm for
matching or you can get more general
problem they make sure intersections and
gabbo and so from 89 so there are a lot
of about rhythms for this problem and
for too many decades of work ever since
we have been able to reduce the running
time from for these problems down to
basically basically the time to do a
matrix multiplication where n is the
size of the input right so so this is
pretty great so is there any room for
improvement that's the question
and if you think about it a little bit
then there might be a little something
unsatisfactory about this running time
here if you look at even this classical
problem like matching and measure
intersection so matching is a really
beautiful problem and for that we do
have running time that is proportional
to end of the Omega but in the case of
matching and it's actually the number of
vertices so that is better than the side
the input to the power Omega because
typically the size input would be the
number of edges of the graph which is
bigger than the number of vertices but
if you go to the more general version
they make sure intersection then
suddenly the best known algorithm has
running time which is input size of the
power Omega
that is a mismatch here like so matching
we have fast algorithms major
intercession we do not write so so maybe
there's some something to to be done
there like and given the tremendous
recent progress in them in sketching
algorithms for linear algebraic problems
where we have been able to reduce the
running time a lot of cases to the
number of nonzero entries of the
problems plus this term that depends
only in the rank rather than input size
perhaps maybe this is the time to
revisit these problems in commute or
optimization and maybe this more that we
can do so that is the hope my hope
anyway so well we don't have answer for
for most of these questions so really
today I'm just going to talk about
basically a small step as to what to
what these these problems so before we
progress further let me define the basic
notions here and this is a bit left
field for this audience so so let's
define what a major it is like so my
chart is basically a collection of sets
that are a general abstraction for
problems in graphs in linear algebra so
we operate on a ground set of elements
and we have certain rules that govern
the the sets that are in am a choice so
you can think of a major is just a
collection of independent set so what
our independence well we have three
axioms empty set is independent if we
have a a big independent set then any
subset of it is also independent and
third property is that if I have two
independent set and one of them is have
fewer elements in the other then I can
always get an element from the bigger
set to expand the smaller one and the
new thing is still independent in some
sense this is an abstraction to
generalize property that you see in the
your vectors if you want to verify it
you can see that this wave from the very
familiar notions of linear vectors and
independent vectors so we can look at a
few example and we'll see a really nice
abstraction and also we'll also call the
maximal independent set to be basis by
this property is the consequence is that
all the maximal independent set have the
same size so an example from the context
of grab are the spanning tree is rick so
the items that we look at in the ground
set are just edges of the graph like so
these are the elements and a collection
the edges is independent if it has no
cycle and so for example if we look at
the red edges here then they would be an
independent set because there's no cycle
among the red edges if I look at the
blue edges here
they also is an independent set because
there's no cycle so again if you look at
the basis they correspond exactly to the
spanning trace of this graph it's an
example of I may try graphic matrix and
then we could look at linear vectors and
items are just you know vector in some
field right and the set of vectors
independent if they are linearly
dependent and we can also note that this
is actually a strict generalization of
the graph case that I just talked about
where the graph could just model each of
the edge it just is simply a vector but
have two nonzero entries but the two
coin it where the edge is incident on
and you can verify that when an f2 so
when you have a cycle you add up those
edges you would get a zero vector back
so they are linearly dependent so that
is a generalization of the graph so this
is pretty general model they a lot
more example of my choice of this class
of linear my choice that is made choice
that can be represented using linear
vectors actually very general include a
lot of combinatorial problems so now we
have collections of basis they are
several fundamental questions that
typically ask and the most common I
guess maybe the easiest one that many
people might have seen in undergraduate
classes would be the question for the
maximum weight spanning trees so I have
now the elements also have weights on
them and we would like to compute the
base of the maximum weight so the way
that we can do it there many algorithms
but one of the way is the cross goes out
with them was something like this
initialized to an empty solution and
then I scan all the elements in the
order of decreasing weight so basically
it's a greedy strategy if I can add this
element while maintaining independence
ever ever and I just scan through them
exactly once from the highest way to the
lowest weight and that will give you the
maximum weight spanning tree this first
course algorithms interestingly enough
you can generalize this to any matrix so
in Maitre we have weights on the
elements so for linear major I have
weights on the vectors like so each
vector might have some value to me and I
would like to compute the base of the
maximum total weight maximum total value
so can also do the same thing initialize
to an empty set of vectors and then I
scan them in the order of decreasing
weight if I can add an element when
maintaining independence to now do that
and at the end I'll obtain the maximum
weight base this is the simple greedy
algorithms and it can compute a maximum
weight base of the majority
so what about the running time if you
look at the abstract setting of a
general mate right then typically we
would assume the tomato it's in some
abstract object that we can access
through queries so I give you a
collisions elements and the alcohol will
tell me is the set of elements
independent or not so greedy is really
efficient because only use n queries so
that is probably about as efficient as
you can hope for so so that is really
great in this abstract model now a lot
of the time people so care about the
special cases right so for specific mate
right
for example if you look at linear
vectors again then we don't actually
just talk about a strap or a course but
we actually talk about the running time
of these Oracle's right if I give you a
collection of vectors checking if
they're linearly independent is I not
cheap of cheap operations so the problem
is that now really no longer seem that
fast because if I have linear vectors in
high dimension then in this step of
checking independence could potentially
take you already out of the Omega time
just to check independence once and we
have to check every time we try a new
elements so the running time is now
actually n times out of the Omega
yes assume that the ground state is
finite
yeah so let's say that the ground set is
finite so there are only the vectors
that are given to you right and they
have widths so you need to somehow
specify the width of the so you can
think of it this way so I have features
that I can buy right so like then they
are only a finite list of them they're
only given and I want to find the
subsets that open maximum value you can
define which you can define on infinite
yes wait there's no artist without down
when you have to define a certain way to
assess so here of course we look at the
case where we have a finite number of
elements n and the running time is
measure with respect to that so I'm
given the collection of vectors that are
already given to me I cannot just pick
cofactors out there okay so the running
time if you know the greedy algorithms
without Oracle's is that actually n
times at Omega at least naively so this
doesn't seems so good anymore so the
question is what what else can can you
do right because this doesn't look the
best possible it's not obvious why this
would be the best possible so in this
work we look at this problem and we show
that there is an algorithms actually
that can compute the output of the
greedy so basically simulate 3d and
compute the maximum weight based upon
linear metric in running time basically
what we set out one which is the number
of nonzero entries of the representation
plus the rank the Omega but then we'd
also need this term n to the leader of
one overhead that where n is the number
of items with the number of vectors and
as the rank these vectors
since the side either side of the basis
so this is what we show ah so well I'll
go over how we obtained this results and
as I said this just may be a first step
to what getting the better understanding
of these auditory Oh problem so we'll
get with that at the end so let's see
how how do we do how do we solve this
particular case so yeah so checking
where the solution is independent
already take this much time in general
this seems to be about the right bound
for the running time if we can get it so
the way we do it is we are will proceed
in two steps
first we'll get a simple algorithm when
the number of elements is roughly the
same as the rank and then we'll use that
as a bootstrap for the case when the
number of vectors is much bigger than
the rank the plan and the key tools here
is of course as we would expect is
coming from sketching the rank so this
is the approach that we hope that using
the sketching tools maybe we can get
better algorithm so this that is where
we start from so what is rank sketching
this is from really nice paper from 2013
and the result is follow if I have a
matrix of size as they need by n and it
has rank R are smaller than both D and n
then we can actually compute a sketch
matrix linear sketch that we serve the
rank that is something that people you
know so the precise parameters is that
we also want to preserve a particular
set of independent columns so basically
you can think of a is maximum with set
of columns that we want to preserve so
what we are going to do is that will
multiply with some sketching matrix on m
to obtain a sketch matrix M Prime
with a smaller number of rows roughly
equals example prank such that with high
probability
we still preserve this set of columns to
be linearly independent and at the same
time we do not blow up the spaz ET of
the input yeah yes so the blow up is
only constant this is only because I
want the high probability thing
yes so so that that is just so indeed
this blow-up is not too important it
could even be constant right so with
these tools we can proceed to do the
easy case first which is the case when
the number of factors is roughly the
same as number of elements in the basis
so we'll pick basically a constant
fraction of these input vectors so we'd
all like greedy we sort all the vectors
in decreasing weight and ingredie we
would go through them one by one and
pick as long as they preserve
independence so here we know basically
divine contour instead so observe that
the maximum weight base is basically
what we do is that we compute the
maximum weight base for the restriction
on the first half of the vector right
because the greedy exactly just run
grading you're the first half and then
grant greedy or the second half so the
maximum weight base is nothing but just
start out with the maximum weight base
for the first half of the vectors and
then once you compute the maximum weight
weight in the first half of the vector
basically we contract the problem in the
following sense like so a contracted
problem the set is independent in the
contracted problem if you take the union
with the contract the construction it is
independent in the original problem like
so basically once we compute the maximum
independent said in the first half we
take these elements as given and now
anything else is independent only if it
is independent when it's early--you in
in union with these selected elements in
the first half so basically this what
we're going to do we are going to
transform the rest of the n over two
vectors so that they're represented not
by the original vector but in the
transform vector over here
so if you work in Euclidean space or
something you can think of this as
rotate these vectors or I should project
this vector onto the orthogonal
complement of the selected vector from
the first half if you work on a generic
field you do something similar because
it's not really orthogonal complement
anymore but you do something similar to
that so you can do this and then you
compute the maximum weight base at the
second half so that is the divine
conquer so we first compute the maximum
weight base at the first half then we
transform the second half using sort of
projecting on the eternal complement not
quite because we're working on the
generic feel but something to that
effect and then you compute the maximum
weight base among these transform vector
in the second half so that is the basic
Devine conquer algorithm in the running
time would look something like this
right we have to solve the problem with
half of the vector and then we need to
transform the second half which take
about this much time because we do some
matrix operation and then we have to
recursively solve the second half by the
maximum weight base of the transform
vector and the running time would be
basically dominated by this mirror term
here and you get the end to the Omega so
this a bus is not quite out of the Omega
but because we walk in this case where n
is all of our so we are in good shape
here
so that is the basic case so it's not
too hard to do the basic case but not
that this transformation here is really
expensive so we cannot hope to do
something like this when we have a lot
of vectors much bigger the number much
weaker than the side the base so instead
what we are going to do is that we'll
use a different kind of divine conquered
so now in this case what we are going to
do is the following idea will sort all
the vectors again but now we will divide
did they get some our part of
I don't know what happened
okay somehow this one slice um yeah
anyway so those the ideas liked it so I
have to the vector solid from haggis way
too low which way right so greedy would
just run through them in eight elements
one by one instead what we are going to
do is that we will divide them into
intervals and each of the interval I
want to know how many vectors selected
by greeting and then we just keep
dividing them further and further
initially we only have one interval but
then as we refine them we have more and
more intervals until we can identify
exactly where the selected elements are
that is a basic strategy and because the
size the intervals in turn even
intervals has very few elements that are
being selected I can compress them using
ranked sketching
so even interval has very few selected
element you can break them up into sub
intervals and compress each of them and
then solve the sub problem on the
compress in evolve so the compressed
problem doesn't tell me what are the
vector to be selected but it will tell
me how many elements selected from each
of these does it preserve the right sune
preserved how many elements to be
selected just don't know which one to be
selected you just know how many and that
is enough for us because once we reduce
the problem to the case when the number
of selected elements is roughly the same
as the number of remaining elements we
can use a simpler algorithms to solve
that case because we feel to our most of
the elements that are not selected
so this filtering step take about
locking iterations so to solve a problem
we need to solve basically lock and sub
problems and that the problem is that if
you do that the size of the from
actually grow because sub problems like
because we compress them they have fewer
vectors but they have non more nonzero
entries because when we do the company
the matrix catching the number of
nonzero entry actually grow up so we
have to make the recursion depth to be
pretty small if you do not want to blow
up the side of the problem and you can
make that happen you can make the
recursion depth to be on the order of
Lok Lak and so will blow up the side of
the problem by locking each time and
side the problem will blow up my lock
and to this power the hole running time
would be exactly what I mentioned
sparsity plus the rankled omega time
this blow up factor
now so that is one part of it but it
also come from the fact that the faults
to solve problem I need to solve lock
and sub problem and extra problem has
the same number of nonzero entry even if
it has the same right then it still have
that lock and lower yeah so so that is
the rough idea of what has happened
because you need to make the parameter
works and it's so I'll just do a very
hand wavy version of it so the a lot of
directions coming from here as I said
this is just the first step in these
problems so one question do immediate
question you could ask is can you
actually get a new linear time algorithm
for this particular case so this is
actually a very simple case so that
might be possible the reason I got
interested in this problem is actually
because of this second question what
happen in the more general problems for
example the classical problem of the
major intersection when you have two
linear a chart want to find the
intersection generalization of matching
and that is a really curious problem
something like this so I'm given two
matrices a and B we want to find a
maximum set of indices such that the
corresponding columns in the first
matrix are linear independent and the
corresponding column in the second
Matrix are also linearly independent
simultaneously we find the maximum set
of indices so this is a really curious
problem there are algorithms with the
running time like I said and of the
Omega where n is the number of columns
of these vectors but is it possible to
get something with specific plus the
rankled Omega I don't know no that's a
very curious question hopefully someone
will we solve it
more questions
oh yeah so so basically the what do what
you do is this so you you take this
vector that you already selected and now
you want to project or not found
complement so what you do is you find
the maximum rank square matrix of these
thing and then you compute a show
compliment of this square matrix and if
you multiply the show compliment with
the rest it wouldn't have the same
effect yeah so that's what
all right let's think way again
[Applause]